things that interest you give you lots
of energy
things you don't want to do you keep
procrastinating which is horrible
nobody says hey you're doing a great job
i just want to send you an email they
say here's five problems i'm having
right now
and here's the storm i'm in today go fix
it the key to motivation
is routine now that may sound boring and
mundane but it's not
[Music]
you know muffy really misses me because
i haven't been in the office for eight
months it's the first time i've been
back in the office since the whole
culvert thing started
now this office is just full of
memorabilia about shark tank
all of our products and deals emmy
awards
but the award i'm most proud of i got to
show you this one
this award says reality
wanted awards the male villain like you
know how hard this is to win i've won it
twice
i got it first to 2014 then i got it
again last year
and in the interim i don't know what
villains were winning but it wasn't me
so i had to get mean again
and now i'm back i'm top villain i just
love it
sure there's enemies share this critic's
choices but are you kidding
male villain that's what i'm talking
about anyways i want to do a little
rant about staying motivated because
it's not easy
it's not easy to stay motivated
particularly in these crazy times i mean
we've had
you talk about covet and you know not
even being in the office and working
from home
all these months been nuts the key to
motivation
is routine now that may sound boring and
mundane but it's not
if you get into a healthy routine and
that includes a lot of things
like for me it's getting up early you
know working out
45 minutes to an hour every day and then
really
into the routine of taking care of
yourself too now
this video as many others is being
sponsored by tiege hanley
and i want to tell you about them yeah
exactly
tiege baby but the whole idea with teach
hanley
is that men's skin care is something
that's kind of new
a lot of men didn't care about their
skin but as you age
and as you expose yourself to the sun
and your skin starts drying out
and you're working out a lot and stuff
you got to care about your skin
so you get a box right you're in a
subscription service very very simple
some products hey muffy
so look for example here's a couple that
i that i use all the time
the deal about going outside is in the
morning just put a little spf 20 on with
moisturizer
that really helps and the one i use all
the time to take makeup off is the wash
because it's got a little pumacy thing
going on in there
so i use this wash at night and i use it
also in the morning
and so you know there's nothing you can
do about that you got to put that powder
on otherwise your skin's too shiny for
the camera
it's a trick of television but i've been
using it for years and years and years
so my big faves are protection with
moisturizer
20 spf and the wash and the reason i let
them you know
sponsor my podcast and my youtube stuff
is
i use the products i do not talk about
stuff i don't use
so tiege hanley check them out if you're
a guy it's really great stuff
and of course when i talk to these
hanley guys i always say hey listen what
about my followers
let's give them a special offer every
time you sponsor one of these videos
so if you click on the first description
you'll get a free toiletry bag
you can keep all this stuff in and i
travel with this stuff i take it
everywhere with me
let's get back to motivation so routine
is part of motivation
every day you're going to get thrown a
ton of [ __ ] is going to hit you
particularly if you're an entrepreneur
even if you're just working in a job
you're going to get emails and texts
about nobody says hey you're doing a
great job i just want to send you an
email
they say here's five problems i'm having
right now and here's the storm i'm in
today go fix it that's
generally 99 of your communications so
when you're working
you have to kind of categorize what
you're going to deal with first now
to stay motivated here's a little trick
that i've used
start your day with the biggest problem
when you've got all your energy take it
right out of the gate
whatever it is it's going to be some
horrific problem you got to deal with it
get it done first generally speaking
there's going to be five to seven things
you have to do every day you won't get
them all done every week
and every day but you want to take the
top three and nail them
and the trick to that is to do nothing
else till you solve those problems
that's a big trick i learned this years
ago i actually post this stuff
the night before a little sticky note
you know
right on the mirror it's very very
useful
so what i do every night is i take a
little mc squares
you know that product that's one of my
shark tank deals wonderful company
and i write down the things i got to get
done the next morning there's no tech
here i actually write it down
stick it on the mirror get up in the
morning
you know work out come back for the
shower start nailing down those things
i always have my phone with me so if i
can start working on one of those things
when i'm shaving
i'll call the guy up and i'll be shaving
getting it done
one of the biggest tricks of motivation
is if you actually solve a big problem
first when you have all the energy at
the beginning of the day
it actually motivates you to keep going
no question about it
now the other issue you've got to deal
with motivation
is be able to take a minute off you know
sometimes when i'm just
fried frazzled could be two in the
afternoon
this is a trick you just go sit in a
chair
and do something completely different
listen to some tunes take a snooze read
a book it has nothing to do with the
stuff you're doing during the day
now the people in the mediterranean know
this trick they call it a siesta they
always take a snooze at one to two and
the food they it's really great
which leaves me a great segue into the
next piece
do not eat shitty food you know people
say oh it's too expensive to eat good
food not so
you really really don't want to eat crap
crap drags you down
what's crap look everybody likes to
snack but you can't eat crap and you
know what i'm talking about
overly fatty too much salt too much
sugar
too much snacking too many chocolates
all that stuff
you can indulge a little bit but your
core base
of the three meals you eat during the
day have to be good
food you cannot run the body
with crap food it just doesn't work and
you will learn this pretty damn fast
now that also means i like to drink wine
you got to drink it in moderation
so i have a little rule for myself i
never drink before i go on television i
never
drink until four o'clock y i'm involved
in the financial markets
so they're open till four i never drink
till four o'clock usually i don't even
drink till about five
when i have my first glass of montrachet
which is a white
beautiful wine or chardonnay my own
wines
obviously i like to do that and then for
dinner i'll have a glass or two of red
so maybe i'm talking about three glasses
here now for the for a lot of people
that's too much but you got to really be
careful on how much alcohol you consume
not just for the booze the calories are
a [ __ ]
you're talking about 160 calories for
eight ounce glass of white wine
sometimes 220 for a red depending on
what it is
and how sweet or dry it is but just
think about that three glasses of wine
you're talking almost a thousand
calories in some cases
you don't want to do that now if you're
going to drink call it 800 calories that
means you got to work out in the morning
for almost an hour and a half to burn
that off otherwise you're going to gain
weight
so alcohol is something i love but
you want to stay motivated nothing
really drags you down more than gaining
weight watching that scale move
up i'll tell you what really i love to
do after i work out after i've had my
shower i weigh myself
and if i'm right where i was the day
before i'm loving it i haven't gained
any weight i'm not trying to lose weight
just don't want to gain any
another motivational factor now here's
something else
one of the big challenges over the whole
kovich dick was losing touch with people
you know even your own family it was
tough
it was a really tough time because
generally you have
you know compadres out there that used
to hang out with maybe see once a month
once a week went out for business dinner
whatever all that stuff shut down
for the majority of people so what i
really made sure i started doing and i
got into this last march is
each evening i would touch base with
two friends i text and say hey
give a minute to talk and we just
communicate staying in touch with my
network
and some of these people are business
associates it's just that i haven't
talked to them in a while i'll just call
them up say hey listen just want to
check and see what's cooking talk about
the industry
what if it's in television or one of my
shark tank deals i want to eat you know
my businesses like you know something
i've invested in
just to touch base with the ceo for only
a couple of minutes
but i find that's very motivational in
the sense that it keeps you connected in
the network
you're still communicating with people
you know there's a lot of
raw books about motivation and you know
patent-like stuff
all this military discussion i'm not
into that
i'm not against it i'm just saying in
terms of things that you find to
motivate you
they have to be things you can build
into a routine you don't just drag off
the bookshelf
after three months of being depressed or
something you got to get into the daily
routine of keeping yourself motivated
and i'm telling you
communicating with other people is a big
factor in that
now something else to think about also
and this really speaks to the whole
kobit
lockdown i try and find a way
to be able to get outside and walk for
45 minutes
i didn't say run i already worked out in
the morning i got that piece down
i'm talking about just getting outside
and walking
walking 10 blocks 12 blocks whatever it
is if you have a dog
whatever take the dog for a walk very
important if you have to wear a mask i
understand it
but just getting out otherwise you get
this crazy feeling after a week of being
inside
and it you know it doesn't matter where
you are even if it's in cold weather put
on a jacket get outside
i do that every day even if it's really
crappy weather
i just get out there part of the routine
and when does that happen sometimes it's
the break i'm taking at two o'clock in
the afternoon i just go for a walk
doesn't mean you can't work when you're
walking you know you put your earbuds in
or whatever you use
and you make a couple of calls you're
outside it's just
keeping you motivated to keep doing
stuff
and you know you think to yourself i'm
looking forward to my walk again part of
the routine
this is the key you know there's another
trick i use some goals take
much longer it's not something you're
going to get done in a day it could be
three months whatever it is maybe it's
you want to
break in with a new client or maybe you
want to achieve some goal
that you know you're a guitar player
you're a painter or something that you
want to achieve on the internet you talk
about the yin and yang side
play guitars you see some guitars
hanging up around here let's say i want
to learn a new riff a really complex
lead something in steely den which is
really tough
that might take me a week or two to
really nail it so
you know i can get through the whole
thing perfectly
and then you've got to keep practicing
it otherwise you'll forget you'll forget
the whole thing you'll forget the riff
but the point is if you're going to get
there
set up a reward for yourself maybe you
say okay
if if i can play that perfectly
i'm going to buy myself another guitar
now i'm guilty of that because i got
like 35 guitars
but it's kind of one of those things
that you reward yourself by and the
other one
in deals for me when i work on a
big deal like something a company that
i'm starting up and i eventually take it
public that could take
four five six years or i do a big
financing what do i do
i always do the same thing i buy a new
watch i got a lot of watches and you
know why i do that
because i remember that deal with that
watch
so that watch becomes part of that thing
that i rewarded myself for
now the only problem with it is watches
aren't cheap
but i buy good watches so they
appreciate in value
and after you buy about five you don't
need any more
but i keep buying watches it's sort of
like a little bit of a disease but i
love buying watches
and for most of the manufacturers now
know i would need a red band because
that's what i wear on television
so i got to go through the whole hassle
of finding a perfect fitting red band
now i don't own any of rubber b they're
not a sponsor but i only use rubber b
because the integration with the watch
is perfect just a little sidebar there
but that's that's part of my
motivational trick now there's a
there's a watch i want to get um
it's a tourbillon it's made by fpjorn
it's a vertical tourbillon
very very rare and whoa is it expensive
other problem is they probably are only
going to make 10 of them now i cannot
buy that watch for myself until i
achieve a great financial outcome in one
of my deals
so that motivates me to go get something
done
now in this case i'm very optimistic
about a certain deal that i'll probably
be selling in a couple of months and
when that happens
what am i going to reward myself with
that fp
journal now
i know that sounds crazy but in my mind
that's a goal
and that watch will always be associated
with that deal
and i'm working on that deal right now
i'm working on it every day
sometimes i'm working on at midnight you
know it's just one of those things that
motivates me as an investor slash
entrepreneur
but i know when i achieve success
bingo derby all i'm gonna love that
okay another motivational hack
don't do everything yourself you just
won't be successful you can't do
everything on your own because you don't
have 100 skill set
nobody does you got to find partners you
got to find allies you have to find
compadres
that you're going to work with
particularly in business you know
all of my deals now i never do them
alone i form a
team it will often seat a company
together we're investors together and we
work together towards success
i do that all the time generally twice a
year but i wrote about a lot of this
stuff i never plugged my books but
these have been best sellers kevin
o'leary the cold hard truth
i like it it took me forever to write i
mean
it's hard work right people thinking
right about quickly this thing took me
like a year and a half
then i wrote a follow-up family kids and
money a lot of the things i'm talking
about are in these books
get them on amazon if you want they're
interesting but it's from the
perspective of making mistakes learning
from them not making
those mistakes again that kind of thing
so motivating yourself to engage with
people
people enrich your lives even people you
don't like to work with that you work
with enrich your lives they give you a
different perspective
a different set of eyes in investing
it's very important you know people ask
me
why do you have advisors that you work
with i say because i want to hear their
perspective on my investments
i want to hear what they think if all
you do is listen to yourself you'll make
lots and lots of mistakes
because you won't take those challenges
you won't take risks the same way but
you've got to hear from other people so
motivation
is about keeping a network of people to
help you motivate yourself
very important one more motivational
hack for you
this is a good one someone taught this
to me years ago
make your goal public in other words
tell a lot of people about it which
forces you into the commitment
broadcast it i am going to achieve this
i'm going to do that i'm going to get
this done
you know it even could be weight loss
i'm going to lose five pounds whatever
it is
broadcast it and all of a sudden you own
it
because everybody's expecting you to
deliver it becomes
part of your own personal
accomplishments it's a hack that really
works
and you continue to broadcast it because
you're committed to it
because others are going to say hey you
said you're going to lose five pounds
you said you're going to do this deal or
you were going to invest in that
or you're going to learn how to play
that riff or you're going to paint that
painting or you were going to read that
book did you do it
believe me when others call you out on
it it really motivates you
try it definitely works when you set a
series of goals up you know if you're
going to do your five things a day
make sure at least three of them are
things that interest you
and two are things you didn't want to do
but you have to if all you have are
tasks you hate
it's really hard to stay motivated so
you've got to blend them together
it's really for me it's usually five a
day three of which i really want to do
and two really suck but i get them done
anyways you're always going to have
things you don't want to do you have to
do you got to call this guy or call this
person
whatever you have to put it in there but
blend it in with some stuff you want to
do
you know what i mean the other day i
wanted to make crepe flambe
i love to be a chef and i love to cook
and i'm pretty good at it
and i was thinking i'd stick that in
with two calls that i really didn't want
to make about business
so i said i'll do one call pre krep
flambe and one afterwards you know what
i'm saying i kind of
forced myself into it was something in
the middle i really wanted to do and by
the way my crepes were
spectacular they were spectacular
my trick is cointreau anyways i don't
want to get into a cooking lesson but
the whole
see i'm interested in that i'm motivated
to tell you about it that's my whole
point
things that interest you give you lots
of energy
things you don't want to do you keep
procrastinating which is horrible
you've got to deal with the tough stuff
too but mix it up
mix it up
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe